Okay, now we've talked about parallel communications patterns.
Check that off.
Now, that we've discussed the general forms of communication
that we'll see among the code of threads in our parallel programs,
let's talk about how those threads can most efficiently access memory in concert.
An important subtopic of this is going to be how to exploit the data reuse
that we saw during all those gathers and stencils codes.
There were a lot of threads often accessing the same data at the same time
and how can we exploit that to reduce the total amount of time spent on memory?
The next big topic is how can threads communicate partial results by sharing memory?
A real problem then becomes once threads are sharing memory
and reading and writing from the same memory
how do you keep them from stomping on each others' memory accesses?
How can you do this safely?
In order to better understand all of these topics,
we need to dive a bit deeper and learn more about the underlying GPU hardware.